a failed former president Donald Trump
was given the opportunity to respond to
uh Kanye West's anti-semitic comments
now this was an interesting
um question this was with
um Larry O'Connor Joe O'Connor Larry
O'Connor from the Salem News uh Channel
and Kanye has praised Trump before and
when you praise Trump will rarely
criticize you no matter what you do no
matter what you say even though Donald
Trump has uh a Jewish Daughter by
conversion and a Jewish son-in-law and
Jewish grandkids and all this stuff
Trump we know Harbors many anti-semitic
beliefs but he's also not going to
attack Kanye over this would be my guess
because Kanye is nice to Trump and likes
Trump and indeed Trump downplayed uh
Kanye's anti-semitic comments in this
just complete implosion of an interview
he's been saying some really uh
offensive things lately about your own
son-in-law Jared Kushner and about
Jewish people uh Jewish Americans yeah
he's attacking your family writ large uh
could you react to that because is this
the guy that you knew
well I haven't really seen the
statements he's made give me a break
dude did watch the Tucker Carlson
interview and he was really nice to me
that's what that's all that matters
that's all that matters listen the
anti-semitic comments including the ones
against my own son-in-law that I didn't
see but he had great reviews for me when
he spoke to Tucker and by the way Tucker
cut out anti-semitic elements of that
interview as well which we later
obtained Beyond anybody he was he was
great to me and he was great really to
Mega to The Mega Movie it was very
impressive I I was uh you know not
surprised I got I always got along with
them I liked him I've always gotten
along with them uh so I don't really
know what statements humid sometimes
he'll make a statement and a lot of
people will uh think it's worse than he
means it to be right guys Kanye's
overtly anti-semitic statements
including listing a dozen different
anti-semitic tropes in that uh drink
whatever interview that I played for you
earlier this week
it was all blown up and taken out of
context I think that uh you know I was I
was uh certainly very uh you you know
what I'm talking about he was really
high on a guy named Donald Trump yeah
he's been saying some
um Trump's approaches
I don't care what he says as long as
he's nice to me that that's
fundamentally what it is
um let's look at a little bit more of
this interview the entire interview is
bizarre again let's get all those
questions answered I'm very proud to be
joined by the 45th president Donald
Trump Mr President thank you for joining
us tonight well thank you very much
Larry it's an honor I know that you're
focusing on the 2022 primaries you're
doing your your rallies and I know that
there's a lot of candidates that you
single-handedly endorse the latest
polling shows a red wave coming how much
credit do you think you deserve for
what's about to happen that's a that's a
really good question to open it up with
how much should we be praising you for
any Republican win in November sir
well I think we deserve a lot of credit
for having done a really good job over
four years so that we had no inflation
we had the greatest economy in the
history of our country we had the
strongest border ever we defeated Isis
uh we would have never had the
catastrophe that's going on in Ukraine
that was not something that would ever
have happened a hundred percent were
energy independent we were going to be
energy dominant in a period of very
short period of time right you know we
would have been supplying the world with
energy we would have made a fortune we
would have brought down the taxes and
many other things right we rebuilt the
military a lot of a lot of things that
we did was that 12 lies in 90 seconds is
that is that actually what I just heard
so as you can imagine not exactly
uh significant journalistic rigor during
this very strange interview but listen
if you're nice to Trump you can get away
with saying anything even overtly
anti-semitic comments about Trump's own
son-in-law must be nice to just have
that simple moral guidepost if they say
nice things about me I'll say nice
things about them we'll take a quick
break and be back after this
when you're looking for a good
documentary to watch you scroll through
Netflix and Hulu for a while there
aren't that many you realize you've seen
the good ones what if I told you there's
a streaming platform exclusively for
documentaries with the best selection
where you won't run out of top quality
documentaries that is curiosity stream
with a massive catalog of the newest and
best documentaries classic titles from
years ago exclusive content you can't
find anywhere else I just watched
Pompeii disaster Street I visited
Pompeii in Italy before I wish I had
seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiositystream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below